and as the tory leadership race
continues candidates uh coming under
renewed pressure to address the cost of
living crisis so let's get more from the
former chief whip and the supporter of
rishi sunak mark harper who joins us now
live mark harper good to have you with
us uh good morning to you so
are we going to see uh rasheed sunik and
liz trust sitting down with the current
prime minister to try and put a plan in
place before the new person that takes
over number 10
no i don't think that's going to happen
but i think what is very important is
that rishi's made it clear
that we're looking at energy bills
likely to be higher
than what were we were expecting when he
set out his plans when he was chancellor
in may and what he said is that that
therefore will require more help being
delivered um and he's going to set that
out in detail uh once we know exactly
what the new energy price cap will be in
october but he's got he's going to see
he's set out but it's going to be along
the lines of the framework that he
already has used so a mix of
rebates on bills and direct support to
those people who are the poorest and
most vulnerable by contrast
liz trustees has said that she's not
going to deliver what she calls handouts
and she's only going to cut tax and the
problem with that is it gives a a big
tax cut to the prime minister
1810 pounds a year but only 59 pounds to
somebody working full time on the
national living wage and nothing at all
to pensioners so i think what rich is
setting out is the right plan which i
hope will provide a loss of reassurance
and comfort to those who are worrying
this winter about how they're going to
pay their energy bills yeah of course so
we'll come onto this dressing room but
we want to push you on this why don't
you think they'll sit down i mean i know
that gordon brown suggested it i know
that it's been suggested again by davia
earlier today you're saying that they're
not going to do it but many people
watching will be wondering why during a
time when we're expecting bills to go up
so massively and people are struggling
to understand how they're going to pay
for those bills you guys aren't sitting
down to try and work out a plan
that doesn't involve starting after the
5th of september
well
very clearly there's a fundamental
difference of opinion between the two
leadership candidates so rishi thinks
that you we are going to need to give
direct support to people um because if
you're going to help the poorest and
most vulnerable you can't just cut their
taxes because they don't pay a lot of
tax uh let's trust things that you can
simply cut uh national insurance but
that gives a big boost to people on the
biggest incomes doesn't help pensioners
at all and gives very little help to
people on the national living wage who
are working full-time so there's a big
difference of opinion there what will
happen
is that the civil service will work out
both
options so that they'll be ready for
whoever's going to win and become prime
minister on the 6th of september but
rishi thought it was very important that
we give people some peace of mind so
he's made it clear that if he were
elected
he would use the frameworks that he's
already set out and would deliver more
help because it's clear that energy
prices are going to be i think about 600
pounds higher we're expecting than we
were expecting back in may and he'll set
out the details of that one's off gem
have confirmed the level of the price
cap which will be at the end of this
month yeah i mean you call it a
difference of opinion but people
watching will be thinking and feeling
anxious that they're going to have to
just wait until they see how much this
price cap is going to increase by how
much more their bills are going to
increase by while you guys are concerned
about opinions and it feels to me like
it's ego that means you can't get in the
room together
well not at all it's just a very
different of approach rishi i think is
setting out the right approach and i
think people can judge him on his track
record so when he became chancellor just
a month later we were faced with the
kogit pandemic and millions of people
were scared about their jobs and about
their businesses um he got the treasury
to respond within days and rolled out a
very significant plan people remember
the furlough
and all the money to help keep
businesses uh going
and they they still remember that and i
think they can look at his track record
he had their backs during that crisis
and when he was chancellor early this
year
he rolled out the package of support
that by the way currently hasn't yet
been delivered people haven't had the
discounts off their bills yet that kicks
in
in october we have delivered the first
level of support to the poorest and most
vulnerable there's more of that still to
come so there is actually a lot of help
in the system that rishi put in place
when he was chancellor of the exchequer
yeah but it is acceptance by you must
happen that it will be inadequate with
the rise that we're expecting to come
and i do wonder further on uh liz trust
and her um
candidacy you haven't held back this
morning in in criticizing her plans and
you haven't held back on social media
criticizing her plans so i do wonder how
do you expect to be able to work
potentially in a government that is run
by liz trust
well two things first of all in a
leadership election the different
candidates set out their stalls and and
challenge each other on the positions
they set out and then when that
leadership election is over
uh whoever wins obviously everyone comes
together uh i happen to think that
russia has a very good chance i feel
sorry mr harper just doing suggestions i
feel a little bit more than that doesn't
it right now because obviously this is
the new prime minister and you are
speaking to the country and this person
will be leading our country through what
may very well be a very difficult winter
for people economically
yes and in fact it's because it's such a
going to be such a difficult winter and
because the single most important thing
that the government is going to have to
deal with this is is this economic
crisis that i'm supporting the candidate
who i think has got the best plan to
help people through the winter we are
going to have to give people direct
support liz trust has ruled out giving
out what she calls handouts that means
leaving pensioners and the poorest and
most vulnerable without the help that
they're going to need to get through
this winter and to pay their energy
bills rishi tsunak thinks that we do
need to help them um and i think that
that message is going to land with
conservative members conservative
members want a government that supports
the most vulnerable and those who need
our help to get them through the winter
and i think in the end that's why
they'll end up supporting rishi soon
after why he'll win this contest and
become prime minister on the 6th of
september
now as you've seen this morning in the
times the justice secretary and deputy
prime minister dominic raab has said
that if
conservative party members follow liz
trust and vote for her they'll be
writing an electoral suicide note do you
agree that
well i do i think if if a government was
elect if she were elected and she
weren't to help the poorest and most
vulnerable people in society which is
what she said she said she's not going
to give them direct support then i think
that would be enormously damaging to our
prospects the conservative party has to
be rooted in reality it has to look at
the situation
facing the country it's a massive
economic challenge and i think you need
somebody who's got the grip
and the experience to deal with that
economic challenge
the voters think that rishi has that
economic experience that's why swing
voters those voters who voted for us in
2019 who aren't currently planning on
voting for us uh massively support him
over liz drussie has a 20-point lead
amongst those voters and if we want to
win that election when it comes then i
think rishi sunak is the man to put into
downing street
and you're happy with the kind of
language use
suicide notes
well i think if the government doesn't
help the poorest and most vulnerable
people to get through the winter to pay
their energy bills and to put food on
the table then i think that will be
electrically very damaging which is why
rishi said more help is needed and you
referred to giving people peace of mind
he's set out the fact that if he becomes
prime minister there will be more help
uh he people can rely on that assurance
looking at his track record through the
pandemic and through the energy prices
he's already delivered when he was
chancellor and i think that will provide
reassurance and peace of mind to people
as they're contemplating what is going
to be a very difficult winter for many
many people